[Musique]
non
vianney malin bonjour bonjour ironique
merci d'être sur le plateau tv 78 pour
ce vip qui vous est entièrement consacré
vous êtes ici à l'occasion d'un
événement prestigieux qui va avoir lieu
bientôt dans les yvelines plus
précisément à versailles et je parle
donc de salon histoire de lire ce fameux
salon voilà vous en êtes l'organisateur
vous en ai dit qu'est ce que vous faites
par rapport à ce salon vianney malin
dites moi tout je suis modestement le
chef d'orchestre le commissaire du slow
milieu commissaire voilà le site
l'aiment c'est devenu une grosse
organisation dont nous l'avons créée
avec etienne de montety qui préside
notre association directeur du figaro
littéraire
nous l'avons créée donc il ya 11 ans et
la 11e édition
tout à fait mais aujourd'hui c'est c'est
plus d'une centaine de personnes de
bénévoles impliqués dans l'organisation
plus de votre équipe tout à fait tout à
fait donc voilà grosse grosse aventure
et là on est dans le compte à rebours
puisque le 24 25 26 et demain c'est
demain ça approche césure donc un
week-end c'est le samedi et le dimanche
de 14h à 18h30 avec des auteurs qui
seront présents ce soir les deux jours
soit un seul jour à nous de regarder
laurent petit temps et plein d'autres
événements en sus que vous avez dont on
va parler bientôt juste comment vous est
venue cette idée qui paraît finalement
juste évidente mais bon fallait faire
tuer massivement parce que ça n'existait
pas avant tout à fait tout à fait en
fait il commençait à y avoir donc on est
dans les années qui précèdent 2008
des événements thématiques liées à la
géographie
voilà notamment qui avait attiré notre
attention et puis on pensait que voilà
le nom versailles rayonne dans le monde
entier bien sûr pour le grand siècle
louis xiv mais mais mais pas que tout à
fait cette année on va parler beaucoup
de 2 2 919 le traité de versailles
voilà il s'est passé beaucoup de choses
dans cette ville qui rayonne et donc il
fallait une manifestation liée à
l'histoire voilà on l'a on l'a créé et
françois de mazières
jeune élu en 2008 a tout de suite
répondu avec enthousiasme à cette à
cette création
d'accord alors est-ce qu'on a déçu
puisque maintenant ça va faire en posant
au niveau de la participe de la
fréquentation par exemple alors voir la
première année la première année on
était quelques quelques milliers une
trentaine d'auteurs voilà aujourd'hui on
va accueillir cette année ça sera un
record 177 hauteur et on espère passer
symboliquement le cap des vingt mille
visiteurs et donc c'est une grosse
organisation les cinq gros libraire de
la ville sont sont impliqués nous avons
déjà il ya quelques semaines passées les
commandes de 15 mille livres
voilà parce que nos visiteurs
là on est à quelques semaines
effectivement de noël oui aussi une
occasion de faire des cadeaux
personnalisés a eu des étiquettes et
dédicacé donc voilà nos visiteurs
repartent pas avec un livre mais souvent
deux ou trois livres
voilà donc ce sont des vivres des
amoureux de l'histoire qui viennent pas
que de versailles mais de tous les
toutes les yvelines et voir au delà de
l'île de france voilà le décor est alors
dites-moi ce lieu principal donc c'est
dans la mairie tous a lieu donc à
l'hôtel de ville
mais vous êtes un petit peu étendu déjà
parce que finalement ce salon il est
dédié à tous les amoureux d'histoire
quel que soit leur niveau finalement de
la culture j'ai envie de dire mais de
comment dire c'est assez large et peut y
avoir des auteurs assez populaire je
pense à lorànt deutsch fakih qui met là
l'histoire à porter tout le monde comme
à des gens très pointu vous avez tout à
fait raison vous avez tout à fait raison
tous niveaux alors on n'est pas que à
l'hôtel de ville aujourd'hui parce que
l'hôtel de ville est trop petit il va
nous sommes à l'hôtel du département en
face et la préfecture ça fait déjà trois
ans depuis trois ans tout à fait nous
avons un chapiteau une grande tente sur
la place de l'hôtel de ville pour la
jeunesse parce que c'est quand même
presque 30% de l'activité du salon les
gens viennent en famille voilà il ya
beaucoup d'historiens pour la jeunesse
va seulement d'aider ou packetvideo non
non non non au nom de du roman de été
n'égale pas forcément enfants à vous
avez raison mais du coloriage aussi pour
le premier âge avant de savoir vivre et
écrire voilà parce que l'épopée
napoléonienne dont on va pas beaucoup
parler cette année l'egypte antique les
chevaliers voilà tout ça ça ça parle aux
enfants
et puis on est à l'université interâges
pour les les grandes conférences on est
à l'hôtel des gendarmes donc le l'hôtel
d'agglomération et cet ingrédient le
sect alors je reviens sur le fait qu'
effectivement les grands historiens de
ce pays les emmanuel de waresquiel et
jean christian petitfils voilà son sont
là mais notre notre adn c'est vraiment
effectivement d'aller de de parler à
tous les français donc les effectivement
lorànt deutsch grand vulgarisateur qui
sort donc en ce moment un très beau
livre sur l'histoire la langue française
ira michael lonsdale qui va nous
replonger dans l'histoire de cette
période douloureuse l'algérie de
tibérine d'ailleurs il en revient juste
d'un un pèlerinage sur ce haut lieu du
du monastère des trappistines n'y étais
jamais allé parce que le tournage du
film les hommes et des dieux s'était
fait dans dans un studio et maroc ou
ailleurs
il en revient pour la première fois et
long qui va nous parler de cette ce lieu
c'est non et très émouvant voilà on a
beaucoup de passeurs d'aider des
journalistes daniel bilalian donc on
insiste beaucoup sur sur la présence
aussi
de c2c romancier jean marie roy
voilà qui à travers un écrit nous parle
nous parle aussi d'histoire ils ont leur
place à notre notre salon d'accord et
alors autour du salon donc de la
présence de ces auteurs vous avez créé
de nombreux événements satellites
je crois qu'on commence par une
conférence de xavier mauduit le vendredi
23 à l'université interâges à 19h sur
transmettre l'histoire voilà xavier
monuc état qui devient un fidèle
finalement pas ce que je compte faire
trois ans qu'il est là je confie à djoko
on a de plus en plus et wii
les historiens qui aiment venir et venir
c'est pas mal comme ça finalement pour
les mêmes pour les parisiens d'abord ça
marche et a tué ses fils et ses
pratiques
voilà donc alors vous avez raison voilà
ce n'est pas que une présence d'auteurs
en dédicace qui vendent des livres c'est
vraiment deux tours et détours des
animations en permanence et les nôtres
et pourrait pour tout le monde
effectivement quelle que soit sa sa
culture son appétence rapport à
l'histoire voilà de façon très sérieuse
on va introduire ce week-end le samedi
d'ailleurs avec françois de mazières
notre notre maire de versailles qui va
animer un un grand débat sur 1919
versailles
j'allais dire capitales du monde est
entré au centre du monde avec serge
bernstein qui vient d'écrire un très
beau livre sur ils ont fait la paix
yat-il session qui vient le grand
historien non aux français qu'ils nous
racontent l'histoire du traité de
versailles voilà comment ces sait
dessiner la carte la carte du monde
à versailles mais y aura effectivement
pour débattre avec lui daniel schluck
est un grand professeur d'histoire de
l'université de berlin qui vient
spécialement je vous rassure il et je
rassure les eaux il est francophone
voilà qui lui se projette sur ce nouveau
monde dès l'entre-deux-guerres
voilà où est là où il s'amuse à nous
montrer des des jeunes figures qui vont
prendre de l'importance dans les seins
et les années suivantes versailles son
creux du monde ça fait parce qu'en fait
vous avez différents terminal le café
des auteurs les grands débats donc ça ça
rentre dans le grand départ au débat
dont 300 personnes c'est un 7-1 face à
face après on donner mon point de vue et
pratiquement parlant il faut s'inscrire
à l'avance oui pour son effectif au
débat et on a droit à deux 2 de grands
débats de contremarques effectué là on
peut pas si c'est ou bien la patrie
succès oblige on voit là on a le
parti-pris d'être un lieu totalement
gratuit donc vous n'avez pas sortir
votre votre portefeuille pour assister à
toutes ces rencontres
mais du coup il faut il faut organiser
donc tous puissent participer
et bien après je disais on avait des
cafés l'auteur ça c'est plus intime
voilà c'est vous êtes autour d'un auteur
c'est interactif vous pouvez kessel
voilà avec un animateur quand même et
tout le monde peut dialoguer
l'interrompt poser des questions et
pareil on s'inscrit elle avant tout à
fait d'accord donc ça ça a lieu entre le
samedi et dimanche seules à toutes les
demi-heures il ya possibilité de
rencontrer son
et pour la petite histoire vous avez eu
des émeutes des histoires de chez pas
des trucs rigolos
je me souviens de la dune que incroyable
aux stands dont distante je sais pas à
la table par devant par exemple il faut
gérer il ya un monde fou parfois vous
excusez pas des bénévoles je crois alors
oui effectivement c'est une grosse
organisation je ne vous cache pas
l'année dernière c'était d'ailleurs le
général pierre de villiers qui avait
créé un peu l'émeute
oui alors il il revient oui il revient
cette année avec un nouveau livre dans
les prochains jours qui va qui va sortir
philippe de villiers aussi son frère ce
sera là une amie avec un nouveau livre
sur ses clovis
donc effectivement nos dvd star oui ce
fut d'y revenir on parle on en a
certainement et les bénévoles on les
repère parce qu'ils sont costumés au
goût du jour
tout à fait tout à fait voilà et quoi
dire d'autre donc c'est juste que
dimanche soir jusque de nos joueurs
et puis peut-être pour ceux qui ont peur
de cette notion de conférences de débats
il ya aussi des choses elles ne sont pas
obligatoires ludique des histoires en
scène ces collégiens à côté moi des
comédiens costumés dialogue en quelque
sorte avec un auteur en lisant des
extraits de son livre donc par exemple
si vous êtes passionné par par le
marquis de la fayette et dans sa dans sa
relation avec washington
voilà bah venait à se cette histoire en
scène donc ça c'est à l'hôtel de ville
dans la salle du conseil municipal un
pack à sur ce livre là c'est le
journaliste guillaume debré qui était le
correspondant pour tf1 pendant 16 ans je
crois aux états unis qui est un
passionné de l'histoire américaine qui a
d'écrire un roman sur la relation entre
la fayette et et washington ont coûté ça
fait rêver ce programme extrêmement
riche
merci en tout cas bravo et puis alors on
se dit oh déjà au 23 au soir
éventuellement avec avait maudit après
donc le samedi 24 vont de 10 toulouse
samedi 24 après c'est un dimanche 25
et voilà pour plein de choses très
enrichissante pour tout le monde
finalement
tout le programme est un concours d
youtuber ne faisait-il vous avez raison
les il se passe quelque chose sur vidéo
en dvd à skis ils sont une quarantaine
aujourd'hui en france à déposer
régulièrement des vidéos d'histoire dont
nous lançons à nouveau après les césars
et les molières lassant le premier prix
du meilleur youtuber d'histoire de
l'année on peut voter avec baignoire
internet on peut voter dès maintenant
sur le site histoire de lire point fr
voilà pour élire le meilleur prix le
prix du public sera remis qui sera remis
le vendredi 23 à l'ugc cette série si
renault avait fait en dix serrano voilà
et bien volontiers il nous reste encore
quelques places pour cette grande série
et l'invite d'aidé au diesel est un
spectateur de thé de 118 à venir assez
grande soirée remise donc sur le privé
où tout à fait donc on se met en ce en
lien sur un lien sur le site jiwa.fr et
on le savait que sur youtube earth ou
non on va écouter vianney malin un grand
merci
c'est très riche qui a plein de choses à
dire mais là c'est fini voilà merci
d'être venu et a très vite
[Musique]